I finally want to teach you about the concept of a standard score.
The basic idea is that for any Gaussian no matter what the mean and the covariance is,
you can state how far inner out a point axis, so let me give you an example.
Suppose this is a point x and now I will give you a different Gaussian that's much wider
with a different mean and the different center of deviation.
If I ask you about the right Gaussian with the corresponding point x in the right Gaussian,
tell me is it here, here, or here?
And the answer you probably picked is this one over here.
Even though in total distance this guy is about as far as this guy over here
because its Gaussian is wider.
This seems to be the more logic of point in relative to the mean and the variance of this Gaussian.
This point corresponds pretty much to this point over here.
Now that's interesting. That's called the standard score.
So given the point x, you subtract the mean and you divide it by the variance
and it gets me this standard score.
Got it. Let's see. Here's a data set 3, 4, 5, 7, and 6. The mean is 5, the standard deviation is √2.
If I now ask you for the number 2 for this specific x, what do you think is the standard score
relative to the Gaussian that fits those data points over here.